Как можно определить свой талант?
Пошаговый план. Это я создал исходя из
огромной литературы, которую я прочитал,
японской концепции Итигай, благодаря
своему опыту и так далее, и так далее.
Первое, просто возьмите, составьте себе
список того, что вы любите. Смотрите,
сколько людей, столько хотелок. Очень
много людей хотят разные вещи. И,
кажется, в этом разнообразии трудно
разобраться. На самом деле все люди
хотят только три вещи. Первое, они хотят
что-то иметь, так же, как и вы. Они
хотят что-то иметь, они хотят кем-то
быть, и они хотят что-то делать. Поэтому
первый шаг: напишите себе три списка.
Первый список, что вы хотите иметь.
Прямо честно, один на один, сидя один на
один, напишите, что вы хотите иметь.
Второе, напишите список, кем вы хотите
быть. И третий список: напишите,
чем вы хотели бы заниматься. После того,
как вы составите эти три списка, первый
и второй список отложите в сторону,
потому что их можно достичь, ставя цели.
Они являются побочным продуктом того,
что вы делаете. То есть то, что вы
хотите, то, кем хотите быть, является
продуктом того, чем вы хотите
заниматься. Поэтому вы берёте третий
список, чем вы хотите заниматься. И
после этого вам нужно проверить, а
получается ли у вас это. Поэтому вы
должны спросить своих близких, друзей и
составить список, что, по их мнению,
хорошо получается у вас. Второй список,
составьте, что, по вашему мнению, хорошо
получается у вас. И третий список,
просто составьте список артефактов
различных дипломов, наград, медалей, за
что они были вам даны, за что вам дали
эти медали, дипломы, сертификаты и так
далее. И из этих трёх списоков, когда вы
вместе сложите, вы поймёте то, что есть
в каждом из этих трёх списков. Это и
будет то, что у вас хорошо получается.
M.